in the last section we saw that the
motif enumeration algorithm that we
proposed had a flaw it assumed that the
motif that we are looking for must occur
in every string in the collection of
strings under consideration which is not
necessarily true in biological
applications as an alternative our plan
is to assign a score to a given
collection of Kaymer's chosen from the
strings so say that we have selected
such a set of Kaymer's which we call
motifs represented here as a matrix we
indicate the most frequent nucleotide in
each column of this matrix by a capital
letter breaking ties arbitrarily so note
that positions two and three in the
motif matrix are the most conserved
nucleotides e occurs in these positions
in every Kaymer whereas position 10 at
the end of the motif matrix is the least
conserved a common method of visualizing
a motif matrix is with a motif logo in
which the size of a nucleotide
correlates with how often it occurs in
the motif matrix taking the capital
letter in each column construct a
consensus string for this particular
choice of k-mers that will also provide
us with a candidate motif our goal then
is to choose Kaymer's from the
underlying strings so that they produce
the most conserved motif matrix then
simply take the consensus string as our
desired biological motif we therefore
are going to define the score of a motif
matrix as simply the number of lowercase
letters in the matrix counting the
number of lowercase letters column by
column we see that the score for this
choice of motifs is equal to 30
we can now restate our goal as choosing
a collection of k-mers from the
underlying strings in order to minimize
this score so we now have a more
appropriate computational problem which
we call the motif finding problem a
group fours algorithm for the motif
finding problem would simply consider
every possible choice of Kaymer's to
form a motif matrix and then simply take
a clue
of k-mers having the lowest score but as
with any brute-force approach we need to
ask ourselves how fast this algorithm is
assuming that there are say t strings
under consideration all of length n then
there are n minus k plus 1 to the T such
possibilities for how to form a motif
matrix then scoring the matrix requires
K times T steps so assuming that K is
much smaller than n as is the case in
practice the overall running time of
this approach is approximately Big O of
n to the T times K times T now the end
of the T term means that this algorithm
is useless for practical values of N and
T and so we're going to need a faster
algorithm so to improve on our existing
brute-force approach we will rethink the
motif finding problem specifically I've
noted here that when we choose the motif
matrix it automatically gives us a
consensus string our new approach will
be to choose the consensus string first
then look for a motif matrix that scores
best against this consensus how do we
achieve this well until now we have been
scoring the motif matrix column by
column however we could just as easily
compute the number of lowercase symbols
and the motif matrix row by row I want
you to note that the number of lowercase
symbols in a row is equal to the number
of symbols in that row that don't match
the consensus which we know as the
Hamming distance between that row and
the consensus string as a result the
score of the motif matrix is just the
sum of Hamming distances between each
string in the matrix and the consensus
string which we're going to write as d
of the consensus string motifs this
discussion now leads us to the
equivalent motif finding problem in
which we are looking for a pattern that
will serve as our consensus string ie a
pattern that minimizes the distance to
motifs over all choices of motifs in the
Under
strings it may still seem that we have
not made our work any easier though
since we are now looking for a pattern
in addition to a collection of motifs
whereas before we just looked for a
collection of motifs however we will see
in the next section that we don't need
to search through every possible choice
of motifs in order to find an optimal
consensus string which is what we're
looking for
you